they have to be doing on purpose i i
hope of course i think they are
i mean of course they are and what i
don't understand is
what what what has consistently baffled
me is what's the end game
it's certainly not true that's certainly
not being a guard dog of
speaking truth to power it's certainly
not being a watchdog for the people
right uh it's certainly not to defend
freedom if they ever got
the the authoritarian i mean the one
authoritarian state that they that they
want i mean my goodness i can't imagine
it would be
i think i don't know if you mentioned
this on the show or when i was when we
were talking
earlier about projecting yeah i think oh
yeah yeah the democrat how
what the democrats project they yeah
they project everything that they do
onto the republicans and just the
strategy that just accuse us
well so republicans of everything that
they themselves do yes there's an
article in politico that says
the gop has no goal anymore it's got no
no agenda they put out no party platform
but it says there's a quote from someone
saying all they want to do
is i don't know post memes and own the
libs or some something like that they
want to win and own the libs
and i'm like that's a projection i can't
look at democrats and see what they want
to do
like i are they for universal healthcare
opposed to it well it's a mixed bag
right and that's it's okay if they
disagree sure but
what do what does everything they do
lead to just winning that's it
does it what what what is burning a
building like you mentioned this earlier
we were unified rush limbaugh tucker
cross and hannity
all came out saying like you know
conservative guys what happened to
george floyd was awful
it was not okay so everyone's unified
you think that would have been a great
moment for this country
what do they do they go burn down
buildings why
because they're not trying to do
anything other than getcha
they don't they when they finally er
it's it's the joker right have you see
you've watched the movies the dark
knight some men just want to see the
world burn
even better when he says i'm like a dog
chasing a car
i wouldn't know what to do if i ever
caught one yeah and that's exactly
what's happening so it's like there it
is
it was i i think it was andrew cuomo he
was like you did it you won what do you
want
i i don't want anything i want to be mad
and they you want to go they just want
to exert power over other people
yeah and so this this to me is i i think
why it's so important for
republicans to take back control of the
house because
you know president trump in in two years
i mean it wasn't perfect republicans
didn't get to pass all the agenda items
that they wanted
uh but they were doing a lot of great
stuff and then 2018 came along
this is right around the time where the
the russia hoax and the mueller probe
was kicking off and
um you know democrats took back control
of the house
and progress in this country and i think
that's a loaded word and i don't mean it
in the way that
you know but but the work on behalf of
the people in this country
ground to a halt and two years it was
just nothing but
impeaching the president that was awful
it's it's true but i mean
in 2016 republicans had everything i
know and a lot of them were giving in to
the russiagate stuff
you know it was disappointing yeah it
was disappointing
it was it was it was disappointing to me
that that
that the republicans seemed to not not
on everything but they seemed to
squander that the majority
that's why you know when i when i talk
about the
the establishment republican and
democrats i'm not fans of either you
know donald trump wanted to pull our
troops
out of afghanistan and it was eight
republicans and three democrats who
supported him in that
and i'm not surprised that you have
still unity among both parties in
opposition to things trump
trump is trying to do but i think it's
unsurprisingly it was
it was matt gates who joined in
supporting the president in his efforts
to withdraw our forces
but i think there's very few republicans
there's like a new wave you know that
are coming in that
are different from the way i remember
republicans the way the republican party
used to be
i think a lot of this has to do with
trump and whatever it is
it's a bigger tent like you mentioned
it's more welcoming to
traditional liberals i mean i'm
i am more worried you know people i i
talk i'm talking to a friend of mine
she made a post saying you know hey
everybody she's a good friend of mine
known her for a really really really
long time like one of my best friends
everybody vote you know everybody donate
to joe biden and i commented
joe biden was part of the obama
administration
and they carried out a whole bunch of
you know foreign policy decisions i do
not like
they there were extrajudicial
assassinations there was indefinite
attention provision all of these things
that i think are horrible for this
country
the espionage act used against
whistleblowers and journalists i'm not
going to vote for someone from the obama
administration
and then people started making jokes
about swapping out biden for cuomo or
whatever and i was like no i'm probably
going to vote for trump and they were
like
they gasped no you know she so she was
asked like how how could that possibly
be
and i said because they just voted to
repeal the civil rights law in
california
because they they they're marching
around and their whole they're screaming
in people's faces
salute us or else you had democrats
lining up for miles you know three years
before president trump
ran on the republican ticket just to get
into the guys parties
right you had guys like jesse jesse
jackson and
al sharpton celebrated president trump
and what he did for the african-american
community in this country
and now all of a sudden president trump
is demonized oh he's a racist of course
that's what they do that's what the left
does again we talked about this the
politics of personal destruction they
have nothing else
uh but president trump just because he
run he runs as a republican he's he's
demonized he's hated
he's the enemy and he's moderate and oh
my god
that is that is the truth that is the
truth and i will tell you that president
trump
he wants the best for everyone he does
not get a fair shake in the media
this is this this is a guy that truly
does believe
of diversity of thought in the
republican party he he will listen to
every perspective that's out there yet
he's demonized as
as some sort of like draconian knuckle
dragger or people talk well i don't like
the way that he
that he comports himself and i say how
many conversations with a construction
worker have you had in your life
president trump came up in the new york
city construction trade
that's a tough business you know it's
tough as nails
you know sometimes people in that
business
lack tact it's just how it is i was in
the infantry believe me i know that's
how it goes
and so just i ask people like
understand that you know when you're
looking at when you're looking at how
president trump interacts with people
i mean does he always say the perfect
thing no but the guy
loves this country he loves and
appreciates
all of this kind all of her all of
america's people he does i know it i've
seen it
and so um
i've never i've never seen somebody
resist group think like president trump
and i appreciate that i think it might
have something to do with ego
maybe maybe a little not yeah absolutely
he knows
he's always struck me as the kind of guy
who's sitting there thinking like i know
what needs to be done
you have know what you're talking about
look you know he and that's that's why
his name's in big gold letters and
buildings are on the plan
all over the world he's he's i and and i
can
uh i i can understand this i've been in
situations where i've worked a bunch of
companies
i tell you what i've worked in these
media companies and i have told them
every i worked for basically just two
different i worked for vice i worked for
fusion which is abc news and univision
and every time there's just countless
stories of the meetings i'd have where
i'd say
here's what you need to do to make it
work and they'd be like i don't know i
don't want to do that and so
ultimately i said i'm going to do my own
thing because i'm tired of dealing with
other people
who don't understand what i'm trying to
tell them and can't make it work but i
can
and i feel like trump probably does that
and so what happens is when someone
comes home says
hey i got this idea he goes no he's very
very full of himself
now i think he did make some mistakes
early on with some of the people he
hired and
that backfired on them now they're all
writing books about them and things like
that
well that that's you know what
bureaucracies do best
is preserve themselves yeah and so
you know people that have worked in
president trump's administration that
that have been in washington for a long
time tim
you know they preserve their usefulness
by
saying oh you know i didn't support
president trump and and in the hopes
that maybe they'll be able to get a job
down the line
i never i'd never i never i never
supported him in the first place see
here's my book let me make a couple
bucks until the next administration
comes along
and maybe i'll get hired again and this
this is what bureaucracies do
bureaucracies protect themselves first
but you know it's it's not even
bureaucracy
look at look at scaramucci cohen
these people are like i'm gonna write a
book and i'm gonna sell it bolton i'm
gonna write a book
so it scares me that we have a political
faction in this country
that not all of them i think a lot of
them maybe start paying attention
but a lot of the thought leaders are
trying to score a buck
quick buck what do i got to say to get
elected
i'll say whatever i got to say just give
me the keys to the castle i mean have
you realized that that's like the
polar opposite of how i am right well
that's right that's why i when i talk to
you because i think that's
not easy running like this i mean you
talk about taking things out of context
i mean
you know i've gone on comedy shows in
the past making tongue-in-cheek jokes
with stand-up comedians and they're
being taken out of context and
oh i hate women and that's not the case
it's
like listen watch the whole clip decide
for yourself you know
don't listen to what uh you know some of
the some of the
the journalists and i certainly use that
term loosely uh don't listen to what the
journalists say watch the clips
yeah on your own well this is this is
this is the left in a in a nutshell
are you familiar with the story of count
dankula no so he's uh he's a comedian in
the uk
and they got way worse than we do
because they don't they don't have free
speech the same way
he made it he made a joke video he was a
nobody he's a regular regular dude
working class guy actually was it used
to be a commie
and he made a joke video where he had he
taught his his girlfriend's pug
to do the nazi salute the joke was
that the dog was the cutest thing in the
world so he wanted to make it the most
disgusting thing imaginable
by teaching it to react to horrible
things he had like eight subscribers
he was not a personality he made a joke
video they arrested him for it
he got he got he went to jail he got
convicted and he had to pay a fine
that's
ultimately how it turned out they ended
up taking the money from him
but this is an extreme example we see
this kind of stuff in the uk
over here it's similar but we do have
free speech it's all about
power cr stomping on people destroying
them owning them
gaining power by any means necessary
they will take anything you say and they
will lie about it
they will manipulate it because i guess
it gives them attention
i honestly don't understand no but i'll
tell you that's why that's that's why i
was afraid to get in this
um i really was you know i've been in
some of the
i've been in life and death situations
hundreds of times in afghanistan but i
was afraid to get in this because i've
got
i've got three small kids you know and i
don't want them to have to go to school
every day
and deal with the bs lies that are
thrown around i don't want them to have
to deal with the politics of personal
destruction i don't want my kids to
i mean i mean i keep coming back to this
but look what they did to brett
kavanaugh they tried to ruin that man's
life
and nothing of what they said was true
but not
all a lie every bit of it was a lie but
at the same time
this country is worth it you know the
people that live in this country are
worth it and
it's worth fighting for and if good
people don't rise up to fight for this
country to ensure the next generation
has a country that's that's rich with
opportunity
we won't survive thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you